have you got a chance to see Victor
webign yet yeah of course how can you
miss him what what have you thought from
what you have seen as
that type of talent and skill and
it just puts a smile on your face if you
play basketball you know because
the evolution of the game is taking us
this far yeah you know I'm saying we got
seven five dudes be able to do
everything on the court you know so he's
inspiring the other to a lot of people
out here I heard a comment he said like
somebody compared him a few players in
the league he's like I think I'll do
myself a uh this service if I compare
myself to one or two players he want to
take from everybody and I thought that
was such a profound statement and uh
made me a big fan of you so the leagues
at least really in trouble when he comes
in and I want to see how it plays out
and
um
everybody's been excited for his uh his
arrival to the league so we'll see what
happens were you able to catch victim
last night I did
um what did you think of him and also
not just on the court but you at one
point were you know the IT guy coming
into the draft like I wonder if you
could share a little bit about what it's
like to be in that position if can think
back that far uh I would do I think of
him I think probably the same as
everybody else think
um
everybody you know we're leaving like
this unicorn thing everybody's been a
unicorn over the last few years but he's
more like an alien
I've never seen no one's ever seen
anyone
um
as tall as he is but as fluid and as
graceful he is out on the floor
I mean that seven four or seven five or
seven three whatever the case may be his
ability to put the ball on the floor
shoot step back jumpers out of the post
step back threes catch and shoot threes
block shots
um
these um
for sure a generational Talent and uh
hopefully it continues to stay healthy
that's what's most important for him
personally and uh but you could tell he
loves the game he was smiling a lot by
playing the game last night
I think it was the two best players in
the draft on the floor last night they
both did their thing and it was uh but
he's a big time player and his school is
a big time player as well for me what I
went through
um
I just thank God I didn't have social
media
that's all I can say
I can't imagine what my life of kind of
I would have been different or what
would have transpired with me with
social media and
um
I'm happy I didn't have social media and
I'm happy I was from a smaller town of
Akron Ohio it definitely just kept me in
the bunker and kept me locked in on what
what the task at hand as a 15 16 17 18
year old kid that made me lock in and I
had the chance to watch him play
a year ago for the first time because my
brother my little brother coasters
played in Nashville and they were
teammates
is incredible man like I believe in 2045
everybody is going to look uh like
Victor you know
um but the way his skills the way he can
shoot the ball the way he can move
uh he's extremely fast for his size can
block shot uh can be a threat in
defensive end he's unbelievable you know
and uh
I believe it's no matter time for him to
you know be in the league and uh
uh for him the case to just keep getting
better keep staying humble and stay
healthy you know a body like that with a
skill set like that as long as you stay
healthy it's going to keep improving uh
keep enjoying the game as much as he can
and I think he's going to be you know he
has he has the chance to be one of the
best not in his age or not in Europe one
of the best to ever play this game like
we have never seen something like that
before
you know and I think it's a good
challenge for everybody and on the
league to have somebody that's 7-2 be
able to shoot over YouTube dribble like
he's a guard to plug shot to run down
the floor uh fast uh
we gotta get ready for this kid you know
he's going he's gonna be really good
have you had a chance to watch uh Victor
win manyama play yet
yeah I watched the uh a little bit of
the game the other day they play again
tonight right
uh
yeah
yeah he's like the 2K creative player
every point guard it wants to be seven
foot
Chico type Vibes but he's he's a solid
town it's great to watch the head of
it's pretty entertaining game uh with
the ignite team so it's dope